foreign
let's go to Mary in Indianapolis what's
up Mary
hi doctor what's up
hey so okay so my question it's even
really a hard one to ask bring it on
stupid for asking it but hey Have you
listened to the show before quite a bit
you are all good man you're in good
there is no weird questions on the show
or hard questions what's up
well okay so my husband and I we have
nine kids together six Armand three are
his nine
nine
all right nine kids
okay yeah and five of them are girls
okay well he
and he is a military veteran and he's
real strong with his beliefs and things
but he says that when women dress real
sexy and provocative that they're pretty
much asking for attention from men and
things like that
okay
and I just I just I don't even know
really how to handle that and when he
mentions it around the girls because if
something were to happen to one of them
I don't want them to ever think it would
be because of you know it's ever
anything that they did or because they
dressed a certain way or you know
yes let's take them off first off the
table for a second this isn't sitting
well with you tell me why there's
something else going on here what is it
oh well one because I don't believe
okay tell me more and
and um two of the girls actually had um
an instance with an uncle where they
were touched inappropriately okay
and I guess that's where it hits home at
you for a while and he's best he was
best friends with that Uncle
and so is he blaming these girls
no but at the same time like he he
refuses to call him a pedophile which I
fully believe he's not allowed to be
around anyone in the family at all
anymore because I made a huge deal out
of it filed a police report told
everybody in the family everybody knew
that had little girls
and there wasn't like we had a
graduation party because the girls are
older now of course we had a graduation
party and he allowed him to be at the
graduation party
and
yeah I just like the kids shouldn't even
have to even see him in this being the
same room with him
foreign
why isn't he in jail
because the police said that um it was
just grooming and there was no evidence
of anything it was just his word against
their work grooming is a crime too why
isn't he in jail that's what the
detective told us because they sent out
crimes against children genetic
detective to the house and that's what
they told us even though CPS had even
been involved because he's done things
with his he got accused of doing things
should I say with his daughter's friends
are these daughters all your biological
kids are they both
no they're my biological kids they're
older now it happened when they were a
lot younger one I didn't even find out
about until way later okay
I would not have these kids around that
man I would not have these kids around
your husband right now
that's just me
not even around my husband
well he's got absolutely no regard for
their safety or care
yeah first I don't think he even
believed it but there's just been too
many allegations
and then since I came forward since I
have made a big deal about it and didn't
keep it a secret other people started
coming up because apparently a lot of
people were keeping things a secret they
always do it takes one person with some
with courage and bravery but the
greatest gift you can give your kids
when they tell you something like that
is to believe them
I want to do 100 that's why I mean I
know you do a lot of it and actually
involved the police if they got a dad
that doesn't
yeah
and then they've got a dad don't be and
here's why I'm digging into this yes
when I dress I'll just say me I'm an old
man when I dress nice I want people to
notice me and so I think it's it's not
it's not being genuine it's being it's
being dishonest to say no dude I'm just
dressing good and sexy and attractive
whatever because it just makes me feel
good that is true it does make me feel
good but I just want people to notice I
look nice I want people to think I'm
good looking that I'm handsome and I'm
not beyond that that's fine and so
whether you're 14 or whether you're 40
or whether you're 55 or whatever I think
there's some truth to that and
I don't care about what anyone has to
say
if somebody an adult sexually assaults a
child
I don't care what that kid was wearing I
don't care what that kid was saying I
don't care what that kid was doing that
kid is a kid
and if there is any sort of
um suggestion that the kids have has a
role to play in an adult
abuse situation
I I ca I'm on I am out before the I'll
be out of that situation so fast
yeah he's not referring to the kids he
doesn't he's referring to like just
women in general because we were
watching the show and this guy was like
basically like harassing this woman
textually and then the guy was like well
you wore a shirt where I can basically
see through it and see your nipples and
then Greg was like well yeah that's true
she wanted that attention from him or
why else would she worn it
you know that type of thing yeah does
that men are hardwired for that type of
thing and that women shouldn't even be
allowed to wear certain things
here's the problem is there's some truth
in all of it
if I wear a see-through shirt I want
someone to say something and that gives
nobody license to sexually assault me or
to harass me
and if I walk into a room and someone's
wearing a see-through shirt it's up for
to me to turn around and leave out of
honor of my wife out of respect for my
daughter out of respect for all sort
right so it's all of it all wound up
together
and so to say the way to solve this
problem I I love how it has been um
women need to be more modest and the
response has been over the last decade
or so or men could rape less right men
could sexually assault less it's it's
both and
it's both in
okay that's true
and so I think the
your husband is using this as something
there's something else here that you're
not telling me Mary and I don't know
what it is and if you don't tell me
that's fine
but there's something else that's not
right
no I mean that's it it just it really I
think it just makes me fall out the
handle I think and I feel like I'm being
irrational because it just makes me so
mad when someone says something like
that have you told him that that I think
you're wrong
yeah and then he gets just gets real
defensive and I probably come at him
wrong because I get defensive because
like I said it just brings back all that
with the girls okay I recommend having a
non-defensive conversation about it
of
you've heard me say this a million times
and it gets cliche after a while but to
go grab some lunch or go grab breakfast
and say hey I'm every time this comes up
these are my girls and I'm a woman and I
want to tell you when you say this I
think it's fair to say somebody shows up
to a bar in a see-through shirt
yes they want people to look at them and
see that they're attractive Fair
that's fair
and
um
telling my teenage daughters
that they are responsible for the
actions of adults in their life that's
just not right so when he says this this
is what they're actually hearing and if
he cares about them and loves them he's
going to be careful about his language
and I think it's fair for them to
understand hey as a guy when you wear
this this is what I this is the story
that I'm telling myself
this is the story culture has told me
about you
right wrong or indifferent I'm just
letting you know I'm your dad that's
fair for me
you see what I'm saying
yeah and he sounds like a guy that's
going to get all mad and blow you off
and at the end of the day you have to
choose do I want me and my daughters
around this or not
yeah he does a lot of times get real
defensive and angry at first then he'll
take a day or two and calm down and then
he'll come back okay after he thinks
about it for a while
that may be because you
you hear the light you hear it and you
hear it you hear it and then you blow up
then he blows up and now now we're not
even talking about the thing now we're
talking about who's right and who's
wrong who's got power in this
relationship and that no problems get
solved there
I think circling back to
um
hey I want to have a hard conversation
with you and I want to take you to
breakfast and let's sit down and have
this discussion and it's going to be
uncomfortable for both of us I love you
I'm not going anywhere but we need to
have this talk
um
here's why this is important to me
um and then have it that way
um
I think that's a much that's a much
better
Avenue to have that talk does that make
sense does that feel good yeah yeah it
does because it usually ends up in a big
blah blah blah yeah and tell them I have
no interest in fighting with you I've
got no interest in blow-ups I have
interest in
letting you know here's how this is
hitting me here's how I'm afraid this is
hitting the girls
and you as Mom you've got a
responsibility to check in with modesty
and with
um discernment and responsibility and
love and here's the you that you're
presenting to the world with your
daughters your dad is a world I mean
your dad your husband has a role to play
in that also
but y'all gotta be on the same page with
this conversation and any side of this
conversation that gets out of whack and
gets accusing you can do whatever you
want and there's no or anybody can do
man now you just gotta mess now you got
a mess you got a mess
I think the the the place to start here
is two adults having a hard conversation
together
and he is correct
when somebody walks into a bar right
wrong or indifferent
there's a story that's a cultural story
that's told
that's true
and
there is no license ever
for unwanted sexual advances or sexual
assault for child abuse from molestation
any of that stuff ever
ever and anybody that tells you
otherwise get away from them as far as
you can
it's a messy one Mary thank you for the
call